(soft music)
- One thing that we were thinking about
when we were talking about friendship,
is I asked the question to a bunch of
the people who work on this show,
do you know why your friends like you?
What we did, is we interviewed
three of Ella's friends
from three different parts of her life.
And we asked, "What do
you like about Ella?"
"Why do you want to be friends with her?"
The first person we interviewed
was a new friend of yours.
- Mm-hm.
- Ashly.
- Crossing from, like, calling someone,
"This is my work friend"
to "my friend friend".
Like, that's a weird thing, I think.
- It's a grown-up thing that happens.
- Yeah.
- Okay, cool, you ready to watch?
- I met Ella about a, actually,
it was almost two years ago.
We didn't become friends
until like six months ago.
- Do you remember what
your first impression was?
- Oh, she's really nice and
chill, but kind of quiet.
Which is hilarious to me now.
- I generally have,
like, a lot of thoughts
and am really opinionated,
and I don't want
people to think I'm a bitch. (laughs)
Honestly.
- Really? So you like--
- Yeah.
- Hold yourself back?
- Yeah,
so I definitely hold myself back.
- And I remember being like,
"Oh, I want to be friends with Ella,"
but not knowing exactly how to.
- Wait, so you had like a friend crush?
- Yeah!
- You had a friend crush on her as well?
- Yeah, she's awesome.
- What she's passionate
about, she's so intense.
And then the rest of her life
is just so fucking chill.
- People, they're like, "You just,
"you're chill, you just
have a chill personality."
And I'm like, "Cool, I"m
glad you think that."
- It's interesting just
like watching this now,
like the thought I just had is,
the things that your friends like you for,
are the things that
people who don't like you,
don't like you for.
- Yeah.
- It is weird to say, like, the
thing I don't like about her
is that she doesn't like
herself enough sometimes,
and it's like, "Dude, you're super cool,
"like, just be proud of that and be into
"that's why people like you."
- Do you think that's true?
- That's true.
Yeah, it's true.
I don't know why I'm
so critical of myself.
But it's, it's awesome to hear that,
and it just makes me feel so much better.
- And so we have another friend of yours
who we're gonna watch talk about
how she became friends with you.
And you guys went through
the experience of college together.
What do you think she's gonna say?
- I don't know.
God, college.
I have no idea.
- I met Ella through college.
We were pot-luck suite-mates.
- Just to look back that you're Skyping
with one of my best friends right now?
- Yeah, so weird.
- You're just drinking a beer,
just, like, hearing about my life.
- I knew she was really cool
and I wanted to be friends with her.
So I'm glad that we, um,
sort of became friends
and stuck together all of college.
We continued to live together
until she moved to LA.
- Wait, so you saw her on Facebook
and you were like, "She's
cool, I want to live with her?"
- Yeah, I, I, yeah.
I looked through all her profile pictures
and I was like, "I'm gonna
get along with this girl."
- A few have friend-crushes on you.
- (laughs) That's so crazy,
because I don't think anyone
wants to be friends with me.
- She's definitely not afraid of people.
She's not afraid of being herself
or tossing out a really quirky idea.
But she's also one of
the most laid-back people
that I've ever met.
She kind of just rolled out
of bed and she's that cool.
- Do you think if you
met today, just at a bar,
like two friends' groups
sort of like meeting together
and you guys started talking,
do you think you would hit it off?
What do you think she's gonna say?
- I don't know.
- Okay, let's see what she says.
- Yeah. For sure.
- (laughs) I mean, this makes me happy.
This is such a weird show, guys.
I'm like, sweating.
- Are you ready to watch
one of your oldest friends?
- Julia's known me through
different periods in my life.
- She's known you the
longest of these three.
- Yeah, so, it'll be
interesting to see if she
has a similar view of me.
- I met Ella in seventh grade.
I don't remember my first impression.
She was kinda quiet, kinda like
the weird girl in the corner.
- She was the weird girl in the corner?
- Yeah, but I kind of was too,
so I think that's why we clicked.
(laughs)
- Why do I look quiet, weird one?
- I think one of my first
memories of her is in school,
we were playing with large,
the large water bottles.
- Of course she's gonna tell this story.
This is, I, I think about this a lot.
It's when I smacked her in
the face with the bottle
and she started crying, right?
- A water jug, exactly, and she ended up
smashing me in the face with one of them.
So that was like my first
real memory of Ella.
Was me being in pain.
- (laughs) Of course she tells that story.
I remember just being like,
"Well, I'm never gonna
"have friends again, cos
my new friend is crying now
"and she'll hate me forever."
- What do you like
about Ella, as a person?
- The first thing that came to
my mind is her impulsiveness.
She just decides she
wants to do something,
she doesn't overthink it, and she does it.
- I wanna note that this is,
I think the third person,
who has called you impulsive.
- Yeah.
I never thought that about myself.
- What does your friendship
look like in 20 years?
- Ah, we're gonna be friends forever.
Yeah, whether that's
long-distance friendship,
like we've done in the past.
I still have a friend crush on her.
- You still have a friend crush on her?
- Yeah, I still want to be her friend.
- Do you feel closer to your friends now
that we did this with?
- I feel like I weirdly
know more about myself,
just from what they were saying.
It's amazing to hear that
they really do like me
for who I am and wanna be friends with me.
Like, that, sometimes you
can be insecure, I think,
that you don't know if people really
still wanna be friends with you.
But hearing what they're
saying about my personality
has been crazy.
- Do you think other people should just
ask their friends why they like them?
- Yeah, yeah, I think
that's a conversation
people should have.
It's really interesting.
(slow music)
- What do you think Ella
should work on, as a person?
- I always push her to work out more.
I work out a lot.
- She tricks me into it.
- She tricks you into working out?
- Yeah, yeah.
- How does she--
- Because she thinks I'm really unhealthy,
which I am if you've seen
me, you know. (laughs)
- Yeah, you're disgusting.
- I'm horrible. (laughs)